17,000 peoples taxi
sweet she's seeing this Reina my town
lost its mother [ __ ] mind
who was it Willy Colson why would you
say that we're bringing all you [ __ ]
to justice
maybe I'll get pissed off and fight back
[Music]
I'm sick of this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
me kill me but she can't kill us all
I guess your generation is a little
desensitized
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god I love this what song this
song give me your enemy I love that [ __ ]
I heard there was a party at Greenwald
tonight you imagine if any of this got
out are you guys seeing this right now
have a Salem just got hacked
you think this is a game who was it
Willie Coulson
why would he say that that's not true
they're lying can't believe it we should
do something how many people are gonna
believe that's how many people are gonna
think that I did this
[Music]
we're bringing all you justice
who knows
maybe I'll get pissed off and fight back
I live for this type of scandal to
others
[Music]
[Applause]
me kill me but she can't kill us all I
guess your generation is a little
desensitized
[Music]
you
you